welcome back to new rockstars I'm Eric
Voss and Rick and Morty proved that just
when you think you're getting a
straightforward Prometheus episode
instead you get a nonlinear but pop an
episode with 9/11 jokes that make you
feel bad about Star Wars which is
impressive because the recent Star Wars
movies already check that box
welcome back to explained our Rick and
Morty after-show where we try to decode
these episodes hidden agendas with
insiders from the show this week we're
chatting with all-star voiceover actor
Tara Strong but first let's look deeper
at season 4 episode 7 titled primordius
its titles a take on Prometheus the 2012
prequel to alien with ridiculously
stupid scientists exposing themselves to
bio hazards and unable to run sideways
while this episode's facehugger parasite
follows the wet egg to facehugger to
body burst ur life cycle of the
Xenomorphs in the Alien franchise the
writers also cited the villain Starro
from the DC Comics a starfish like
extraterrestrial that asexually spawns
spores of itself attaches to hosts faces
and controls their bodies floors oh and
its inspirations reproduce in evolve
rapidly but our heroes Rick and Morty do
not they don't evolve they're terrorists
they're incapable of empathy or real
change they begin the episode with no
memory of how the face huggers attached
to their faces to begin with they
violently slaughter their way out of the
situation as they always do but then
halfway through the episode we do
something that the show's never done
before we jump way back in chronology to
establish the in media stressed
circumstances of the opening act and we
discover that the glories of facehuggers
weren't really that bad and capable of
industrial feats and beautiful passion
well it made me uncomfortable but I
don't King Shane the episodes writer
calls Rick and Morty the villains of
this episode comparing them to the
rebels of Star Wars who do kill
multitude to stormtroopers with acts of
terror that are okay just because the
stormtroopers served space Nazis they're
the stock bad guys of every movie like
in a Star Wars movie you feel completely
fine murdering thousands of
stormtroopers you don't think about it
but then we just wanted to switch that
to like humanize these evil aliens I
always wondered does the face hugger
have dreams of its own episode embraces
mourning Rick's lack of empathy even
more than usual yeah
kind of good when there's no guilt ah
yes it's like in Star Wars yeah just
like in Star Wars go nuts already drops
down at the Gunners seat like the ones
on the Millennium Falcon and then he Yas
like characters like Luke Han and thin
dude under lines immorality switched by
putting them in the driver's seat for a
911 style attacks like popping bubble
wrap
honestly I'm proud of us for not totally
would have been cheap yeah real
low-hanging fruit we're better than that
yeah they swerve past the Glore so when
towers not out of a genuine care for
life but because of their own met a
selfish guilt out of making a 911
reference but then Pearl Harbor on the
other hand yeah I think that's it bounce
so yeah now later Rick justifies their
violence alongside their other high body
count episodes maybe we went too
hardcore on these guys what do you think
we never go back to a place we've
already been you know how many
adventures we could get out of purge
planet Morty gear world
I don't sequel it's called integrity
look who's purging now ended with the
most violent slaughter we've seen on the
show and in Morty night run Morty's a
version of violence in gear world ends
up being one of the most apocalyptic
ends for a society in Rick's reason for
not going back to those places wasn't
out of fear of the violence in his wake
but out of this weird creative integrity
but this time Morty and Rick do return
to their carnage and it's so wrecked
that the episodes director admitted the
artists of the episode we're a bit
disgusted some of the boys were like
uncomfortable working on the upside it's
it's it's it's dark it gets dark the
episode goes back and shows us the
humanity of the race that was
slaughtered yes it's a bit weird and
pseudo incest II to see the face huggers
Steve and Bruce make out with the voices
of a boy and his grandfather but I'd
keep my mind both characters are voiced
by Justin roiland
anyway so it's less incest than it is
the roleplay masturbation the glory so
race is right to want to put Morty and
Rick to death they're terrorists
responsible for so much murder the
universe in the multiverse would be
safer in a better place without them but
Rick Morty and summer they escape by
bursting all of them and when they go
home they admit that unlike the
civilization they eradicated they have
not evolved at all maybe we don't tell
people about this one did we at least
learn something that we suck and
everyone sucks I guess that counts and
they in the episode thinking they're in
[ __ ] neg but nope that's too
sophisticated for these monsters instead
they get schwifty and [ __ ] on the floor
[Music]
interestingly this whole debate over
who's the more uncivilized lesser
evolved species was addressed in the
original alien part of the reason it's
my favorite film when the Android - Oh
kinds of humans were lesser evolved
compared to the exquisite xenomorph and
therefore the humans deserved to die
II still don't understand what you're
Tina Mustaine perfect organism you
admire it wears purity yeah that kind of
purity is more applicable to the gross
facehuggers then
to the terrorists who wiped them out by
911 a Pearl Harbor that's a sentence
okay is this for explanation legit or
this [ __ ] will get some second opinions
but first folks in order to get these
after-show episodes out to you so
quickly
I am literally writing and shooting them
in the middle of the night so it helps
to get a solid night's sleep when I
finish so I can get right back to
rewatching the episodes frame by frame
well thanks to helix sleep for helping
me out and sponsoring this episode
helix sleep makes personalized
mattresses made right here in America
and shipped straight to your door with
free no contact delivery three returns
in a 100 night sleep trial to choose a
mattress helix made a quiz that takes
just two minutes to complete and matches
your body type and sleep references to
the perfect mattress for you if you like
a mattress that's really soft or one
that's really firm you sleep on your
side or on your back or on your stomach
or if you sleep really hot with helix
there's the specific mattress for each
and everybody's unique taste I took the
quiz and I was matched with the lux
helix mattress because I wanted
something that felt perfectly medium and
I sleep on my back to make it easier for
the sleep paralysis demon to plank on me
I love it I'm sleeping better and I'm
waking up feeling more refreshed and
ready to take on the latest evil Morty
conspiracy theories I love helix Italy -
take my word for it helix was awarded
the number one best overall mattress
pick of 2020 by GQ Wired magazine and
Apartment Therapy just go to helix sleep
comm /r explained take their two minute
sleep quiz and they'll match you to a
customized mattress that will give you
the best sleep of your life they have a
10 year warranty and you get to try it
out for a hundred nights risk-free
though we can pick it up for you if you
don't love it but you will felix is
offering up to $200 off all mattress
orders in two free pillows for our
listeners and helix late comm /r
explained that's helix HCl ix
sleep comm /r explained for up to $200
off and we are back joining me is one of
the most familiar voices in animation
from series like Teen Titans unikitty
Powerpuff Girls and on Ricky Morty
characters like tinkles Stacy and last
week Morty's assassin disguise did you
create the disguises Terra's strong
thanks for joining us Tara hi guys
thanks for having me and always welcome
back to the show super fan and face
huggy in Paris
played survivor I'm reading Tommy
Bechtold relieved to be here yes all
right this episode crossed a threshold
with a 911 drug we should say an avoid a
911 joke think they swerved at the last
second but being both avoided and
steered back into it at the same time I
think if you if you say the numbers 911
close sequence you're you're making a
911 references yeah there's no bones
about it
it's like when you were a kid and you
like you don't know what I'm doing
behind this hand but it's terrible they
know yeah we're doing it yeah we know
what you're doing but as this episode
also points out Morty and Rick have done
far worse war crimes over the years
thousands are dead as a result of their
actions do you just think it's accurate
to call these characters terrorists at
this point are they meant to be rooted
for anyway or do we just laugh at them
going forward it's funny that we root
for them they're despicable I mean they
really are it's so and it's like
nothing's off-limits there's no
boundaries nobody's safe it's like but
you still root for them you love them I
mean it's like the most loved animated
show no I can think of in a really long
time for me personally my kids really
like it and they're 18 and 15 so to have
something that they're really into like
really excited what do you think Tommy
yeah I I think it's interesting because
it's like you see like in other media
like Avengers infinity war Thanos was
clearly the protagonist but you never
really were rooting for him whereas Rick
and Morty are front and center obviously
the type of characters of the show yeah
they continuously do despicable things
but I guess they're just so fun you know
like it's all it's almost like following
the cool kid in high school that you
know it's bad you shouldn't follow him
you shouldn't drink beer with him in his
dad's garage but you just want to its
charisma I guess I guess they have the
charisma they're like hell leaders you
know that's just a description I mean I
feel like as long as they remind us that
they're not role models they can get
away with a lot more but also whenever
they go too far to say
don't follow our example we're not role
models the fans also backlash against
that they're like well hey we've been
following you off this clip for three
years now you tell us it's not okay in
addition to the whole 911 thing there
was also this weird moment and it was
very weird one of the creepier moments I
think we're like they're face huggers
professor love for each other embrace
but they and it was clearly the aliens
that were doing that but they retained
the voices of Rick and of Morty so
there's some incest implied but like but
also it's weird what do you think it's
Justin roiland it's doing the voice of
both characters do you guys think it's
possible to go too far on the show are
there jokes that crossed any lines is
there a line at all I mean that seems a
little surprising I don't I I don't
think they have any lines I don't I
think they're getting away with
everything somehow you know dude there's
some but sometimes you just have these
shows that do like for me for me the
biggest one I'd like that would be drawn
together you know where like anything
goes and everyone gets away with it but
yeah I think not it'll like shock people
in the moment then they'll be over it
and wait for the next one yeah I got I
feel like piggyback on that it's like
they they do things that you're like oh
wow this is the one of the most shocking
things I've ever done on the show and
that almost just opens a gateway to like
how can they top it's like you know and
because they're fake obviously you're
like alright these are these are
fictional characters like you're not
that it's not as horrifying as like on
Game of Thrones when when Cersei and
Jaime Lannister are you see like two
human actors doing it here you can kind
of disassociate I guess a little more
it's a little less I don't know just
slightly less than than the actors
anyway yeah no that is something that
that Game of Thrones got away with that
it definitely should have is the whole
fan culture of shipping this brother and
sister to stay together like rooting for
them to be each other's soul mates like
there's nothing okay about that but
weirdly they got away with it I thought
it was interesting how both this episode
and last episode ended with this weird
call to like
interdimensional cable it's just sit
down and watch interdimensional cable
like I I'll be interested to see if next
episode does that as well do you guys
feel like maybe Rick and Morty might be
like trying to urge itself to return
back to the simpler bits of just one-off
vignettes where they can just make jokes
as opposed to paying off any kind of
stories or developing character seem
like there's a lot of story payoffs
right now yeah you know I don't know
that some some episodes don't feel
connected but listen I know too much so
I can't say too much but I will say that
it continues to entertain be funny delay
like you're never let down by Episode
III I don't think there's one episode
like well that was that wasn't great
they're also great yeah and it's the
show has its formula now to where even
if you weren't crazy about one episode
like there's enough there to like that
it it's it's not like the story is so
crucial that like well the I don't like
where they're going with the story cuz
really the vehicle the joke or the
vehicle of the show or is a jokes and
the concepts and how quickly they read
through all and some of them are like
for sure funnier than others I've sat
and watched episodes where I'm like you
have to pause that I'm like the last
couple although I enjoyed them but some
of them are just so funny well Tara the
one that stands out in my mind of that
was season two's Total Recall that's my
favorite episode and obviously you you
voice tinkles in that episode in the
moment where it just goes into the
musical sequence the magical bedtime
land it was like the peak of that
insanity and I gotta ask you what was it
like recording that character oh my god
it was so much fun like they wanted her
they wanted her to have like a little
bubbles feel to her and at the time like
you know we we go first so we don't see
the animation until after so I didn't
know it was going to be like that I had
some idea in my head of how it was gonna
look but it came out so much more fun
and so much cuter than I had originally
thought it was going to and it's such a
genius episode it's so clever
I was just stoked that there was a pop
figure at Comic Con that I could get yes
as we learned last episode it is just
about this selling the toys cylinders so
there's a buck to be made I love that
and I one thing I loved about the
tinkles character and like all the
characters you played there's like a
sense of familiarity to where we feel
like tinkles was always part of that
show the way all those like those viral
characters popped in it's like oh yeah
they've always been part of this party
were there any other kind of improvised
bits that you did when you were
recording the audio for that a little
the scripts are so well written we
mostly stick stick to the scripts but um
you do have that sense with a lot of
characters and then just this last
episode of character came back oh yeah
yeah ever it off Winkler right I mean
maybe maybe tinkles will come back one
day I don't know but you do like these
characters have always been around right
yeah and who's real and who's not real
and who's who like knows exactly what's
going on
yeah there's no established rules we saw
last episode cannon is just like a word
that's always in quotes on the show like
characters die characters cut back
there's a multiverse at stake here and
at no point is any character alive or
dead now obviously Terry you've worked
on a lot of shows how is Rick and Morty
different than the other shows you've
worked on well as an animated series
most most animated series we work
together with the other actors Rick and
Morty you're by yourself just with the
crew no other actors in the studio at
the same time which there's good and bad
like when there's other actors in the
room you get to play off them so if
someone says something a funny way you
might respond in a different way because
you know as the actor you're listening
to everyone too so if someone's like we
gotta go so you don't have that benefit
of playing on the other actors but at
the same time you have a little bit more
time to get it right and make it perfect
and it's just you in that room so they
really focus on your character a little
bit
and there's such a delight to work for
they're always so happy it's always a
happy environment to go into work for
them they always have some toy for me or
so I'm like Rick and Morty skateboard
for my kids or something like that and
and they always surprise me you know we
don't often I don't even think I've ever
got out of script in advance
and that's very common for boys where
you get in there you kind of jump in
it's just it's one of those shows that
you can't really predict how it's gonna
go other than it's always gonna be fun
it's always gonna be hilarious there'll
always be a few little extra characters
thrown in like can you do this one and
can do this extra character there and
then and that's fun to watch the episode
and try and find them yeah yeah I can
imagine that's and you know even if you
did have the cast in the room it would
mostly be Justin right like it's either
him or sometimes Dan will get in there
and into voices like it feels like
already kind of all within his mind
anything like oh that show right that's
true that's true
yeah but they use a smaller studio and
it's just one at a time yeah it feels
like a labor of love a very intimate
process but you know what's interesting
about Total Recall and last week's
episode never making more tea this
episode interdimensional cable all the
references to that and several other
episodes they're all these vignette
based stories and I reckon Morty strikes
me as a show that gets bored with its
own story so it has to move through them
quickly and tell like multiple stories
and episode and do you guys why do you
think Rick and Morty leans into this
kind of sprint storytelling is there a
method to this madness is it trying to
say something grander about how how we
should interpret stories that we
shouldn't get too attached to any one
particular story maybe you know it's
been interesting this season I mean
they've kind of referenced it along the
way but this season there seems to be a
lot of like we don't need to try too
hard we try too hard and this is why
things got messed up between Rick and
Morty like they keep coming to the
conclusion of like if they had just done
something easier they would have gotten
into the mess so I wonder like it feels
almost like a we were being set up for
something like the way you said they
would keep returning to watching
interdimensional cable at the end of the
day
like that seems to be a theme that they
keep saying like would we try too hard
bad things happen and I think with the
stories it seems to be like the moon
there could be a metaphor or a reference
to the writing like when they try and
make the story's too convoluted it goes
off the rails whereas if they stick to
simple structure I'm not sure I mean
that's just to me was one thing that
stuck out as they keep referencing if
they had taken the easy way out things
would have been better which is a funny
lesson obviously not necessarily true I
think that's true and I think also one
of the things that keeps people coming
back aside from the comedy and the
writing and the acting and the visuals
every it's such a great collaborative
process and combination of genius things
that go together and make this show so
great is this sort of current I think
collective consciousness about looking
into aliens and powered alone in all
these different dimensions and different
universes and how do you become
enlightened and all these things that
happen when you die and I think without
sticking to a basic story they can jump
in and get like ten different ideas
within one episode yeah and I think that
there just seems to be a sort of
overlying theme like around the world
especially right now going on about like
what what is what are we doing here you
know yeah I hear that that that is a
good point in because the world has
gotten so complicated and so many tropes
have been done in sci-fi storytelling
Rick and Morty seems to hold itself to a
higher standard of not just telling one
basic story like for example I found
this episode interesting it's called
primordius it's clearly referenced in
certain things about the Alien franchise
in Prometheus but it's not a Prometheus
parody that's just like you know the
surface of it but then it goes into
these deeper darker places and if you
you know look back on Rick and Morty
that's kind of what it always does is
it's never just a parody of one thing
it's it's kind of like four or five
episodes and water also genius at the
flashback sequences sequences like I
didn't really see that one coming even
though I'm like oh whoa yeah I agree
I completely agree yeah we're so used to
Rick and Morty starting in the middle of
things as some kind of insane adventure
that we were just kind of like we
shrugged it off out whatever they're
they got facehuggers they're getting
eggs who cares but then yeah we see the
backstory to that yeah that was a very
interesting right turn I didn't see
coming well Tara we're very excited we
know you can't say much about the
upcoming episodes but we're very excited
to hopefully be listening closely and
hopefully hear your voice show up in
future episodes of Rick and Morty and we
really appreciate you joining us this
week this has been great it's been a
great discussion thank you well I'm
super excited about it
fair enough fair enough that's this
week's episode for explaining everyone
again big thanks to Tara and itami for
joining us always great to have some
wonderful people to chat with especially
during these weird times where we're
talking to screens and listening to hear
buds but where we're getting through
this and we appreciate everyone tuned
and then you can get early audio
versions of this show by subscribing to
Rick's plane wherever your podcast you
can follow me on social media follow two
rock stars subscribe to this channel for
more Rick and Morty breakdowns and a
reminder that the breakdown of the
episode of all the hidden animation
details and jokes that's gonna be coming
up in another video and I will close out
this week on our favorite moment this
episode
[Music]